simon
well i did say um farouza um i thought
was going to be the favorite if it came
down to this time limit i'm not really
sure why i said that to be honest but
i i honestly think this is just a throw
a coin they're both amazing blitz
players so it you know it really is 50
50 i think yeah here we go the blitz has
started it has started and it's the
english opening
uh black's bishop coming out now
white just pushing a pawn forward
they'll just get developed they'll get
their pieces out into the center
and transfer the battle to the middle
game very sensible strategy especially
in blitz you don't have to think too
early in the game
just develop you just kind of
yeah control squares control the center
and what do you guys think about this
choice ferruja if i remember correctly
actually used this opening in the
candidates tournament against ding loren
so for roger sticking to something he
knows magnus of course knows everything
about the openings
about all of them pretty much i think
it's a wise choice by magnus i mean i i
think
the english is a good opening but this
is more like you know try to get a small
advantage keep all the pieces on the
board um and just push and here you get
a space advantage this is a quite a nice
structure generally for white to have
but of course black knows the stuff as
well here creating some problems with
that pawn but i don't know i i i like
being white in these positions uh
personally so i'm a bit biased in
white's favor
yeah and uh i'm not sure in my case this
game is still following dingle ren
against aloreta fruga it still was
following and then i
yes no not anymore okay
pushes the pawn defending the center but
either way i mean the whether or not
ferugia
is following that game he will have
studied the ideas from the black side
uh look at black's clock time as well
barely spent a second for roger up to
this point continues pushing trying to
destabilize white over there on the
queen side
that left flank and magnus will he react
i was going to say by pushing a pawn
blocking things up or more dynamically
getting the white pieces into gear and
simon you like this because white has
more space white has
slightly better development right now in
the center white's knights look pretty
good yeah i mean they they call it it's
a bit like what they call a moroxy bind
set up which is where you get this light
square bishop pointing towards the
middle and uh controlling
the middle with a bit of extra space and
white is also as you as you mentioned a
bit better developed here black's got to
get those queen side pieces into the
game um and i can also see white having
a half open file a weakness that black
has in the middle of the board that pawn
being a problem i mean these are just
little things black's got obviously good
pieces and counter play as well
so still in the balance really early
days as yet definitely early days and it
kind of feels like white has the slight
but slightly better long-term prospects
and
black of course
has a very solid position and active
pieces and i wasn't expecting this move
from
magnus
i was expecting the b pawn to push
itself up one square forward
yeah i mean magnus is not scared of
basically doing some damage to his pawn
structure here because if black ever
takes
um with his pawn on the side of the
board he's going to have the better pawn
structure in the long run so all he has
to do is go pawn takes pawn and and
white's pawns are then separated and
they can never connect as we see here so
long term wise actually black has the
better position structurally here's but
piece pieces are all on bags this side
so it's a bit of a double-edged
situation at the moment yeah black
spawns compromised as well when ferrugia
allowed that trade of knight for bishop
magnus kind of frowned he grimaced he
was like oh that doesn't look good for
you mate i've seen that face before when
i've made mistakes blunders against
magnus must be so off-putting you know
you play a move and you get the grimace
every move
is like
but uh either way white's got full
control yeah i mean look at the dark
square bishop i was about to say i mean
this is what you know the grimace white
dark square bishop is just cutting
across the board now
and it looks like a fantastic long-term
piece i mean
yeah
something went wrong there for black
definitely in that little excursion
and he actually has the option of
getting the bishop pair as well um
and uh well ali reza is desperately
going to try to double his rooks along
the a line just to
attack a potentially weak pawn
but is is this kind of enough to offset
everything else that's wrong with his
position
it doesn't look like it looks like the
real action is actually going to happen
towards the black king as simon
mentioned white's dark square bishop is
the unrivaled minor piece it's pointing
towards that black king sooner or later
white also has that four versus three
pawn advantage on the king side they'll
step towards that black king they'll
create some real problems
and uh
it's nice to keep it kind of in your
pocket capturing that remaining black
bishop with the white knight would see
two bishops against two knights that
imbalance it's unclear who it favors in
general but uh when it's this open
probably the bishop's first magnus
though he wants to play on both flanks
both sides of the board activating his
remaining piece
some threats at some point of that dark
squad bishop jumping out the way and
white's rook hitting some pawns and
he's just being greedy here magnus he
wants the positional advantage and he
wants kind of the dynamic advantage of
his pieces being marketed all right
remember there are two blitz fight
breaks going on inside the arena duda
and prague also playing and let's
quickly hear from prague's coach ramesh
about prague playing these thai breaks
ramesh coach of pregnant
prague isn't necessarily
as comfortable with the faster time
limits i see
yeah it's
been getting used to this shorter time
control uh we have been before the
lockdown we are likely focusing on
playing standard time controls but
since the loved one we have been
focusing on rapid time controls as well
so is getting with each tournament is
getting better i guess and do you feel
it's good enough to compete in this
format
it's
too early to judge uh make a judgment
call on this he's still an upcoming
player he has not yet reached his peak i
believe so only when he's reached you
speak probably we should judge whether
the peak is enough or not i still
believe we can grow this extra point is
really important now for the total
standings are you nervous at all as a
coach no i'm not really worried about
the standings as such uh to just compete
at this level and the proof is worth
that's what i'm more focusing on rather
than the standings
thank you so much ramesh
and the bar is all the way over to
prague's side with the white pieces in
the first blitz game against young
christophe duda that's why it says that
one point it can turn out to be
very important two points for a winner
and blitz star breaks one point for the
loser the bar is also over to magnus
carlson's side do you think he will win
this first game david it's beautiful for
white uh white's rooks look great right
now better than the black rooks which
are staring at a very well protected
white pawn white's minor pieces we've
mentioned the white knight the white
bishops beautiful the white queen now
joining the action
i just don't really see how ferocious
going to hold this it looks like
tactically as well the black knights are
very poorly placed
i have a feeling that magnus is just
going to rearrange his rooks and move
them away from the left and
maybe place them in the center
and get ready for the
that uh king side action
yeah exactly magnus can do pretty much
anything he wants right now he does
eventually trade off his knight for
black's bishop so now it is two bishops
against two knights but it's it's clear
the bishops are better pieces both on
their longest possible diagonals black
has those two knights stuck sadly
defending each other especially the
black knight at the top of the board bad
piece better pawn structure for white
everything's in white's favor but we
have seen magnus struggle to convert
advantages in the playoffs against duda
yesterday for example in the blitz
clock time's ticking down as well
ferugia needs to survive until they both
have around 30 seconds and then it might
get a bit more random but right now it's
just full control for white
okay
simon
what do you think yeah
looking good yeah just just the same as
same as what you said basically um it's
it's looking great for white i mean
you've even got ideas of bringing the
you know the queen in at some point
you've got everything i mean you've got
the two bishops you've got control of
the open file
and black's knights cannot find any good
squares you've always got to look at
your opponent's pieces see their
potential and if you look at black's
pieces they don't really have any
potential to improve think where those
knights can move to they can't really
they don't have any outposts so um it's
a position which you would have thought
magnus will convert like um over to
stats person but i'd say 95 of the time
should we say what do you reckon
predictions i'd say but um but i think
david mentioned the time
is is one of the only factors i think
which could uh you know go against
magnus here he is down to one minute 20
seconds now so
smiling meanwhile
is that because of the position because
it's so beautiful right now was he still
listening to something a bit
humorous
he must be listening to something but i
mean it doesn't seem to be distracting
him from his play because again he's
doing everything perfectly and the great
thing about this position for magnus is
that there's really no way for ali reza
to kind of mix things up the position is
not that many minor pieces on the board
and there's no way to attack because
yesterday we saw things go wrong when
there was so much activity on the board
and magnus just look at that he's just
steam rolling with those pawns on the
right
that's a pawn storm incoming yes i mean
the position is very easy to play right
i mean you you literally just well look
at that i mean he even even leaves his
queen on pre uh he's enjoying this a bit
too much i feel at the moment so uh
those pawns are killers and um this is
unnecessary but it's flashy and probably
strong yeah if the if the white queen is
taken by the black knight right now then
the black queen falls and
that only favors white
the black queen looks like she has to
run away
maybe she swings herself across the
board or maybe she steps back one square
but that will only give magnus a free
hand to continue the attack you know
looking very very good for roger now
below on the clock about to take under
one minute he's a speed monster he can
just he can play 50 moves in a few
seconds but in this position it's just
about whether he survives that far minus
did make big blunders in the blitz
against judah yesterday is this a
different magnus we're seeing today a
lot more sharp maybe
it looks focused
despite the smiles occasionally the one
thing i will say about magnus okay
black's queen getting active there are
some threats now uh but magnus lately in
tie breaks he's not been doing so well
he lost against duda yesterday in the
tie breaks norway chess he lost nearly
every uh tiebreak i think he lost four
in a row uh four in a row armageddon
matches at some point
um so yeah he's it's not been great for
him not the usual kind of ruthless
nature that we're used to but
here he's just so direct going for
checkmate going for that black king
yeah magnus is in his element in this
type of position
he's just uh all his pieces are working
and uh now just take a look at that pawn
on e6 it's just bulldozing open the
black position
yeah i mean the black king is devoid of
any defenders really
and there are tactical issues as well
with black's knight at the top of the
board
it's hanging by a thread does magnus
take back with the pawn here okay i
wasn't sure about this it does allow
black's pawn to move out the way there's
some defense maybe with his rooks on the
seventh rank
i thought he would take with the queen
but i think he'd take when the queen
looks very straightforward but uh it's
still very strong
or
can do ken ferruga fight back here he's
given a check gives the check the white
king will move to the corner and now
farouza has to i mean the one one thing
is if it does get complicated when
they're both under a minute you
mentioned it this is where farouza might
might have his good chances you know he
might actually
excel over magnus in these quick
complications he doesn't have much time
though played it he's played at the rook
defending now
but uh maybe you can just leave the
queen on this square in some scenarios
not sure whether you want to as magnus
do you want to complicate things but
where does white's queen go
if it retreats the best you can get is a
queen trade so i think mack just has to
give his queen here if he wants to win
this game and i wonder what the top
going on with the time because uh it
does say that fruits clock has run out i
i'm pretty sure that is not the case but
um would be popped up on the screen if
it hadn't
would have said okay but he's very short
then they're both getting under 30
seconds we know that now
um but what's he got to play here you've
got to give up the queen which is just
instinctively risky there we go he
doesn't care he doesn't care he's done
it before and uh
seconds left on the clock getting
complicated it's getting really
complicated
this is messy this is really messy i
mean
you can take so many pieces here just
guys at home don't look at the computer
try and calculate this position for
yourself it's it's it's a lot to
calculate uh tonight is coming in if you
allow that black knight to come to f2
and check you you will lose to what we
call smothered mate yeah okay he gets
rid of the knight that was important and
now magnus does give you sweet
wow what a variation and he's got bishop
takes here and it looks like this is the
the key move right the killer move that
black rook in the corner is trapped has
to give itself up for this pawn and now
magnus will simply take this rook it's
two rooks against the queen normally
that's imbalanced but here it's all
about that remaining white pawn yeah and
uh also checkmate will end the game that
knight drops it's two rooks and a bishop
against the queen it's too many material
too many pieces
this one is going to be magnus he can
give a check with his rook here
yeah no to pawn he can just move this
rook that's attacked out of the way and
then
the bishop does a great job doesn't it
stopping any checks you know white's
bishop is is a key piece and this is
forcing
uh the win now
yeah magnus makes an equine he's two
rooks and a bishop up one brook drops
but it won't be enough wise king will
run to safety
got a cross check here in a lot of
positions we talked about the cross
check earlier
we might see that here black's trying to
check out of trouble but um it's not
going to work no perpetual here yeah the
checks will dry up they'll run out in a
couple of moves time the bishop jumps
back to defend white's king will move
next the white queen will jump back and
defend and
there we go magnus takes the first blitz
game wow he now takes the lead in the
match magnus carlsen fruija in five
minutes blitz game number two he has to
win for joe to take it to an armageddon
tiebreak wow this is